hi i'm drew barrymore and i just want to
say to all the moms out there
that i get it i know what being a mom is
all about and it is
the greatest thing you will ever do it's
also incredibly hard
heart strings pulled laughs galore hair
tearing out oh my god it's everything
but it is the greatest love i have or
will ever know
[Music]
hi everyone i'm chelsea clinton i'm a
mom of three hi everyone i'm cynthia
germanotta and i have two amazing
daughters stephanie who you may know is
lady gaga and natalie who is a wonderful
and up-and-coming designer hi i'm ali
wentworth i have two adorable teenage
daughters hey guys i'm molly sims and to
all the mothers out there we all know
that motherhood is actually not always
glamorous
i have vivid memories of the first time
each of my three children peed all over
me one it was while i was trying to give
him a bath and it just went right up on
me one i was trying to
change a diaper similar trajectory and
for my daughter i thought i could like
change her diaper while she was standing
up and that didn't work out really for
her or for me and yet i wouldn't trade
any of them for anything in the world to
all you moms out there trust me i know
that motherhood is not always easy but i
have to say
it's what i love the most it's how i
identify the most what i do want to say
though is as my daughters get older i
still just want to be a mom so i maybe i
fall into that category of helicopter
mom and they're frequently reminding me
mom we got this so i'm learning to back
off it's one of the hardest things that
i've ever done but i have to understand
and respect that they're grown women and
let them go out into the world and do
their thing i remember years ago on
mother's day i was sitting in bed
waiting for
cards candy flowers
i got a post-it note that said love you
mama
so i had a emergency family meeting and
i called in my husband george and the
two daughters and i had to educate them
about mother's day and it might have
been a little passionate because i said
i
live and breathe and bleed for you
so i expect a little bit of love in
return so all i can tell you is
it's a work in progress i have very
young kids
i have a just turned five-year-old
six-year-old and nine-year-old and i
thought
we haven't been skiing
coveted
haven't really done a lot traveled a lot
let's go skiing
let me tell you the struggle was real
none of them know how to ski which was
really fun when you have three kids
three different ages and none know how
to ski they don't like their boots they
don't like their gear they don't like
their mom we ended up having a fantastic
time i
literally carried them up the mountain
the struggle was real i love them i love
them dearly
let me tell you something
i needed a drink i needed 10 drinks
motherhood it's so fun i think that's
why i hide
in my closet with my husband sometimes
and we have like a date without the kids
in my closet
it's true
so it may not always be cute or easy but
it's always worth it and i'm excited to
celebrate moms this mother's day thanks
for having me happy mother's day just
the happiest happiest happiest
healthiest mother's day to all the
hard-working moms everywhere happy
mother's day drew and to all the mothers
out there it is truly the best and i
miss my mom thank you for having me drew
happy mother's day it takes a village it
takes a city really
you